of people who would challenge Trump it
puts them in a really difficult
situation because it means people like
you and me ask them questions such as
well was the election stolen is it right
that Mr Trump should face all these
indictments did he do anything wrong
does he deserve to be tried under the
racketeering laws for a criminal
conspiracy and they're terrified of
these questions because they're
terrified of saying anything that will
annoy the Trump base so as things stand
at the moment
he is the Republican candidate that's
just the way it is the unforeseen things
can happen which by definition we don't
know but at the moment he is the
Republican candidate